hey youtubers is Charlie the Game of
Thrones finales this weekend so I wanted
to talk all about Aegon the Conqueror
and the early history of the Targaryen
family even houses that hate the
Targaryen referred to Aegon is the
greatest King that Westeros ever had his
biggest achievement to date is uniting
the Seven Kingdoms although he really
only united six kingdoms and Dorne came
into the fold later that happened about
eight generations later that's why Dorne
motto is unbent unbowed unbroken but
there's actually a lot of really cool
Targaryen history between the doom and
Aegon's conquest real quick sidenote to
the actual king that signed the pact
with Doran was Baylor the first he was
known as Baelor the Blessed the one that
built this big set the one in King's
Landing where we seen all the weddings
and the funerals whenever people talked
about Aegon the conquerer though they
just omitted that that little fact about
doram because they wanted to keep their
heads and they didn't want to get doused
in wildfire he was such a big deal
though that the arch masters of the
Citadel changed the calendar to honor
him so when we say King Joffrey died in
299 al L refers to after landing
although it's a little bit wonky there's
BC before conquest and al after landing
technically the conquest begun in 2 BC
so it select the calendar is just a
little wonky it'd be more accurate if
the AL was AC and it was after conquest
George R Martin goes a long way to base
a lot of these little facts on actual
real world history and I'm sure there
are a lot of inaccuracies in the
Gregorian calendar we will actually have
to talk about false narration in the way
history is remembered in the Song of Ice
and Fire at some point Martin has said
that the false narration exists in the
series that's AI characters remembering
things that are false a really good
example of that is when Tyrion keeps
asking people about where his first wife
is Tywin
Jaime feeds him a lie that she only
pretended to love him
that's false narration so whenever a
character tells a story just be wary
that they might be remembering something
falsely but as much as Aegon the
conquerer is a point of origin for
modern Westeros he was not the first
Targaryen dragon rider in the Seven
Kingdoms Dragonstone up over here was
never completely cut off from contact
with the Andals the Valyrians colonized
it about 200 years before Aegon's
conquest it became the westernmost
outpost of the Valyrian freehold they
used it to make money on the shipping
trade in the
area it really started out as more of a
stronghold but it's basically built on
this active volcano if you didn't know
there is an active volcano underneath
Dragonstone the only evidence of the
volcano today is just steam rising from
natural vents in the ground the name of
the volcano is Dragon Mont but I don't
think it's ever been referred to on the
show stands just says it is full of
dragonglass
of course that's going to come in handy
at some point but there's an extensive
series of tunnels beneath dragon stone
and they're there been many dragons that
have roosted their dragons just
naturally liked to roost near active
volcanoes which says a lot about the
Dragons of ancient Valyria being found
around the 14 flames and for any tinfoil
Theory crafters out there I know you
know people are always wondering if
there's a secret clutch of dragon eggs
beneath dragon stone there is no proof
of that but it's totally possible
historically you would think that future
Targaryen Kings would have moved all
existing dragon eggs to King's Landing
that's what the dragon pit was created
for to be like a giant roost for the
Dragons although it was a pretty
terrible one if there are any new dragon
eggs to be had on the show logically you
would think that one of Daenerys dragons
would switch genders and they would mate
with each other dragons can do that like
they haven't explained it on the show
but in the series dragons can switch
genders starting with the doom of
Valyria in a nice Targaryen there were
five rulers of Dragonstone before Aegon
was ever born like I said though they
didn't do a whole lot other than make a
ton of money from the ships passing by
through the area the shipping trade and
they did have dragons but the only one
that was still alive the only one that
was originally born in ancient Valyria
that was still alive during Aegon's time
was balerion the black dread the two
dragons the Aegon sisters rode Veigar
and MARAC seas they were hatched on
Dragonstone
but the Targaryen family historically
was not buddy-buddy with all the other
kings of Westeros they didn't hang out
all the time but Aegon and his sisters
did visit a lot of different big places
they supposedly visited the Citadel in
Old Town all the way down in the reach
they spent time in Lannisport I mean
they traveled all over agon is the one
that commissioned that giant map of the
Seven Kingdoms that sits in Dragonstone
that Stannis is looking at when he's
still at Dragonstone so he was
preoccupied with the Seven Kingdoms in a
way that his predecessors were not and
even though all the
petty kings of Westeros you know we're
continually fighting with each other
it wasn't until things got really bad
between Haran also known as hair
in the black in Argyll actor andin also
known as our galactican great names I
know they sounds super nice so when a
Don was about 26 Argyll a creature out
to him to help him deal with hair in the
black Harun was king of the crown lands
and he had started annexing all this
territory and was slowly getting ready
to move in on our galaki world over the
area that's known as the storm lands
although a lot of that encompass what is
now the reach this isn't a historical
map so all these boundaries were just a
little bit different during their time
so what happened is those are Galax a
GaN his daughter's hand in marriage in a
bunch of land south of this river here
like right on the border of hair in the
blacks land he wanted to create like a
Targaryen dragon buffer between him and
Harrenhal Aegon saw right through it
took a hard pass on the third wife
because he'd already married his two
sisters countered with the proposal that
if our khalaq basically gave him most of
the Stormlands in you know part of what
is the reach over here as well as marry
his daughter to orous Baratheon his
champion so this is where things start
to get crazy our collec gets super
pissed at the idea of having to marry
his daughter to orous Baratheon who he
calls a bastard and sends the hands of
Aegon's messenger back in a box Aegon is
super pissed and finally says enough is
enough and after about seven days of
deliberation with his generals declares
war on the Seven Kingdoms so he's not
just responding to this grave insult
he's tired of all these petty kings
being so belligerent why is it such an
insult to call auras Bharathi and a
baseborn bastard well it's rumored that
he is the half-brother of Aegon the
conquerer that would make Oris like the
Jon Snow of the Targaryen family so
Aegon the Conqueror and Ora thean are a
lot like Robb Stark and Jon Snow he
eventually went on to become a khan's
hand he became the first hand of the
king and his nickname in a funny twist
of fate became Oris one hand because he
got his hand chopped off just to tie
these characters even more with
characters on the show so Horace was
captured in the in this Dornish conflict
ransom had his sword hand chopped off
just like Jaime Lannister his son or his
son was named Davos and they fought
alongside
savage Samwell Tarly
that all happened after the war conquest
but I just I love how those names make
you think about characters that are on
the show right now so that was like the
beginning of house Baratheon like once
they conquered the storm Lance he gave
them two or aspera thean which is funny
when you think about the modern-day
animosity between house Baratheon and
House Targaryen so houses that once used
to be really friendly like you know say
starts the Lannisters hundreds of years
later might be bitter enemies the same
is true for all the other great houses
of Westeros so let's pull out the map
here so Aegon lands at the area that is
now known as King's Landing you guessed
it the first places that he takes are
the storm lands in the crown lands does
when you had the famous burning of
Harrenhal
that that's why it looks all melty
because one of his dragons melted it
then he moves his army Southwest takes
the reach then King Turin bends the knee
it was even an in-built on the spot
where he kneeled called the end of the
kneeling man it showed up a couple times
drank book to arya gets taken there by
the Brotherhood without banners and
Jaime and Brienne stayed there briefly
after she first started her mission to
take Jaime back to King's Landing
so then Aegon marches on the Vale Dorne
and old town Dorne obviously as I
mentioned was a total wash but after he
marched into old town a conquer he was
crowned ruler of the six kingdoms inside
the starry Sept and given a new crown
the old crown that he wore was the just
the simple circlet of Valyrian steel the
books only talked about that first crowd
so it's possible that that new crown
that he got he only wore like that one
time future Targaryen Kings always
modified their crowns to their own
preference really like the biggest
artifact that got passed down generation
to generation unchanged was the Valyrian
sword black fire some of you guys have
actually asked me to do a video I'm like
where all the special Valyrian blades
are most of them still exist I mean they
haven't been sucked into a black hole or
anything but the funny thing when you
think about it is is you know before the
doom Valyrian swords were super common
like in anybody that was a member of the
freehold probably could have
commissioned their own Valyrian blade it
would be really cool if Varys and
Illyrio tracked down black fire to give
to Daenerys before she marched on
Westeros don't know if that's ever gonna
happen but I'm just saying to be pretty
badass the blades that Aegon melted down
into the Iron Throne there were actual
about a thousand of them were from all
the conquer people the people that
didn't bend the knee this is what it
actually looked like
it took almost a hundred people 59 days
of like beating metal and bull Aryans
dragonfire to reshape all those blades
into the chair the rumor is is that the
rulers that bent the knee like Torrance
Stark didn't get their blades melted
down so supposedly there is no stark
blade in the Iron Throne Aegon died when
he was about 64 years old and
unfortunately as is true with real world
history a lot of his successors ended up
being pretty weak it's like when your
dad is that successful unless your name
is Daenerys and you have three dragons
there's no way you're going to top
conquering Westeros
Daenerys does have a lot of visual and
metaphorical parallels with Aegon the
conquerer but Martin isn't overly
simplistic on the way that history
repeats itself I mean we'll have to see
how the show deals with Daenerys army in
season six and seven but Dan and Dave
are really good about including little
Easter eggs from the side stories to
like the dance of the Dragons that's not
something that's overly explained in the
main novels you have to read like the
side story for that here's my big
question for you guys do you feel like
Daenerys story will play out in a very
similar way to Aegon the conquerer story
do you feel like Martin wants us to feel
like they're almost the same person like
she's the second coming I don't want to
make any Christ's analogies or anything
like that
there are definitely characters that are
just as important as Daenerys on the
show but she feels very much like Aegon
the conquerer the really cool thing is
is that martin is actually going to
write a book about the history of the
Targaryen family just called fire and
blood but it's not going to happen till
after he finishes the Song of Ice and
Fire
which is probably gonna be like six
years away so a really big reminder the
finale is tonight I'll post my video
after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it
I'm also giving away a signed copy of a
feast for crows what I'll probably do is
I'll do my season six predictions on
Monday before I do my QA and then the
bonus videos that I do after that we'll
just be dictated on whatever WTFs happen
in the finale so just be sure to check
out those videos whenever they post
there'll be some extra giveaways going
on too so while you guys are all waiting
for that to drop you can click here for
my episode video and you can click here
to learn all about the night's king in
azor Ahai thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five
we're almost there almost time for the
finale